MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
LEWIS DARTNELL: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you all very
much for coming along.
My name's Lewis.
I'm a research Fellow up at
the University of Leicester,
although I commute
from North London
up to Leicester every day.
And I completed my
PhD a couple of years
ago just down the road at
University College London, UCL.
And the field of
my actual research,
my day job in the
science labs, is
in a new field of research,
a new field of science,
called astrobiology,
which is all about looking
at the possibility of there
being life beyond the Earth.
So I come from a
biological background,
and in the last
couple of years got
an enormous amount of planetary
science, and particle physics,
and computer modeling,
and mathematical analysis
techniques to look into
the big question about
whether there's life out
there, if there's, perhaps,
bacterial life on
the surface of Mars.
And what I've been thinking
about for the last two years,
for this new project, the
hobby I've been doing along
the side, for this new
book, "The Knowledge:
How to Rebuild Our
World from Scratch,"
is on something
completely different.
I've gone from the science and
helping the hunt for aliens
to talking about how you
might reboot civilization
from scratch.
And this is the starting
point of a thought experiment.
Let's say that
this has happened.
There's been some kind
of global catastrophe,
some kind of doomsday event,
some kind of apocalypse.
And you've woken up, let's say
with a hangover, the morning
after the day before, the
day when the world as we
know it has ended.
And you've kind of
picked yourself up
from the rubble and dust off
the dust, dust yourself off.
And you've fallen in with
a crowd of other survivors.
You're in a kind of
post-apocalyptic world
with a community of survivors.
And this is the
kind of trope that I
think we're all pretty
familiar with already.
This has been in plenty of
cinema films and sci-fi novels,
from "I Am Legend" to "The
Road" or "The Death of Grass."
There's a good
history of this kind
of post-apocalyptic narrative.
But the question that
I've been trying to ask
is what to do next.
What happens now?
How can you pick
yourself up, right
from the basics, from
the very fundamentals,
and rebuild a
technological civilization
from the ground up?
What kind of stuff do you need?
What kind of fundamental
processes and principles
would you need to know?
What would you want to have
condensed down to a single book
that you'd want to
have handed to you
in this post-apocalyptic world
that told you how to rebuild,
how to reboot the civilization?
And the conceit is that
that's the book in your lap
right now, that "The Knowledge"
is this single tome that
tells you how to
redo or rebuild all
the functions of a
modern civilization,
of a technological civilization.
And the reason I wrote this is,
first, I was fascinated by it.
It's an interesting thought
experiment to go through.
But I think it's also quite
relevant and perhaps topical,
especially right now.
Because I get the sense that
all of us in the modern world
today have this kind of
feeling of disconnect,
that we don't really have
that much of a real sense,
real understanding,
and certainly
no hands-on,
practical experience
of how a lot of stuff
is really done or how
things are made in the
modern world today.
And if you really had
to, let's say if you're
in this post-apocalyptic
scenario,
if you're knocked back to
first principles, do any of us
really have the foggiest idea
how to take a handful of seed
and walk out to a
muddy field and make
food come out of that field?
How do you reinstate
agriculture?
What are the
fundamental principles
you need to know to
reinstate farming?
Because it is not as
simple as you might think.
Farming is a ludicrously
artificial process
you have to go through.
Even though plants
grow naturally,
it is not in nature's
best interest,
if you like, to have
a monoculture of all
the same crops growing
in very high density all
in the same place
and not have it
hit by disease or by pathogens
or pests or something.
You're trying to
rigorously control
the ecology of a farm, a field
to grow food for yourself.
So how do you do that?
How do you get
metal out of rocks?
How do you make the materials
that we rely upon today?
If you can reach
into your pocket now,
there are probably a
combination of metals,
and plastics, and then
perhaps some glass.
How do you make
that for yourself?
How do you dig raw
substances, base substances,
out of the ground, and then
process them or transform them
into the materials
which are most useful?
How do you go from
a raw material
to something which
is useful, that you
can use for a function?
And this is what I've
been trying to talk about.
This is the research I've
been doing for "The Knowledge"
and trying to piece
together, chapter by chapter,
these different themes of
communication technologies
and transport technologies
and mechanisms
and substances and chemicals.
And the very
beginning of the book
is playing around
with this idea of what
I call the "grace period."
Because if there were to
be some kind of-- let's say
that the best possible
way for the world to end
would not be an asteroid
strike or a nuclear war,
because it would leave
the world in tatters.
You'd find devastation
around you,
and it would be very, very
hard to reinstate farming
when the fields
themselves are poisoned,
when there's radioactivity
from the fallout.
So the starting
point for the thought
experiment that I
picked up on, the best
possible way for
the world to end
was some kind of viral pandemic,
perhaps something like avian
flu or swine flu, that
spreads incredibly quickly,
with our high-density,
urban lifestyles today
and intercontinental flights and
transmission of diseases very,
very readily.
And it wipes out 99.99%
of the world's population.
So the people have
gone, and there's
only a small community
of survivors left.
But the stuff is still here.
You can still go and
scavenge in a city
and get the glass,
and the metal,
and the timber and stuff
you need to repurpose
and rejig and jerry-rig
stuff to keep yourself going.
So the first chapter of the
book is talking about this grace
period, how you get this
buffer zone, if you like,
where you get a couple
of years, perhaps,
maybe a couple of decades, maybe
a generation to work things out
for yourself, to go through
this process of trial and error
before it becomes a
mater of life and death
to grow food for yourself.
And one of the calculations
that I sat down and scratched
my head was a sub-thought
experiment, if you like.
If you were to be locked
in an average supermarket
with fresh water, unlimited
fresh water, a way of disposing
of your waste, so kind
of sanitary conditions,
how long could you survive
in an average supermarket
before you starved to death?
How long would the food in the
supermarket sustain you for?
And so clearly
you'd want to plan,
play some kind of
optimal strategy.
You eat the fresh fruit
and bread [INAUDIBLE]
first, because they'll
go in a matter of days,
perhaps a week or two.
You could then move on to the
dried pasta and the rice, which
have a persistence time of
several months to years.
And the largest reserve
of preserved food
would clearly be tin cans,
would be the canned food.
So I went around an
average supermarket,
which was the one in
[? Angel Islington, ?] and I
noted down and counted up and
multiplied up all the food that
was in there, and
knowing the persistence
times of each category
of food, and worked out
that you could support
yourself for 55 years living
on the sustenance of just
a single supermarket.
And that would go up
to 63 years if you
don't mind eating the cat
food and the dog food.
[LAUGHTER]
LEWIS DARTNELL: So you've
got time to play with.
If you multiply it out to
the society as a whole,
to the stored sustenance
of the United Kingdom,
the nation as a whole, for
a small community of perhaps
several thousand, maybe a few
tens of thousands of people,
you've got decades before
that food would run out,
and you'd have to work out
the principles of farming
to keep yourself going.
Water, of course, is going to
be another primary consideration
for you, and it goes by
repurposing everyday substances
you can scavenge from the dead
cities, the abandoned cities.
You can purify water very,
very adequately using something
like kitchen bleach or swimming
pool chlorine, so sodium
hypochlorite and
calcium hypochlorite,
and you just dilute them enough.
And this is exactly
the compounds
they use in the public water
supply to purify water for you.
Or even more simply
than that, all
you need is an empty plastic
bottle, like this one here,
and you fill it with water
and leave it in the sun.
And then there's a process
called solar disinfection,
or SODIS, which is
recommended by the WHO,
by the World Health
Organization,
in the third world as a tried
and tested method for purifying
drinking water for the very
simple and fundamental reason
that the last thing you
want to catch in a world
without antibiotics is a really
simple infection that could be
prevented by just having
your wits about you
and being aware of germ
theory and basic hygiene.
So use SODIS to purify
drinking water for yourself
by just scavenging some
empty plastic bottles.
And you'd want to keep an
electrified lifestyle going
for you.
This is a car alternator.
You can rip out
the bonnet of a car
and jerry-rig them to some kind
of windmill or water wheel,
turn the spindle, and
regardless of what speed
you turn that spindle,
if you generate
12 volts across the tunnels,
you can recharge deep cycle
batteries, which you
can scavenge from things
like golf buggies or
yachts or RVs or caravans.
They're the best kind of battery
for storing power long-term
compared to a car engine.
And what I keep trying
to do in the book
is come back to real
examples in our own history
where similar scenarios
have occurred.
And this is a city
called Garazda,
which was cut off in
the Bosnian-Serbian war
by the Bosnian army.
And they had food
drops and medical drops
from the Red Cross, but
they were completely
isolated from the
national grid, from power.
It had no electricity.
And so they jerry-rigged, they
bodged, and created these water
wheels for themselves, using
scavenged car alternators
with these wheels
turning the current,
and from these platforms
they tethered to a bridge.
So a lot of this you can root
back down into real examples.
This isn't just speculation and
arm waving for the sake of it.
There are some really
great examples.
And I've come back to
POW camps a couple times
where people have
bodged stuff together,
things they can scavenge
from around them.
If you want to keep your
cars going after the diesel
and petrol has run
out, there's a process
known as gasification.
And I've got a very short
video to show you in a second.
But this is my gasified
stove that I made for myself
for this video that's up on
YouTube and on the book's
website as well.
And this is, again,
ludicrously simple.
It's just a big,
[INAUDIBLE] tin can,
with some holes around the
bottom, a smaller tin can
in the middle, again, with
some holes at the bottom.
And when you put your fuel,
your bits of wood in there,
the holes at the bottom draw in
through the air and the oxygen,
and it burns nice and intensely.
But that's kind of
what we're familiar
with from any barbecue.
What's novel about
these gasified stoves
is you have a ring of
holes at the top as well,
and that draws in
fresh oxygen, which
meets, is reintroduced, into
the hot gasses, the vapor,
and the smoke, which
is itself combustible,
is re-mixed with oxygen, and
you get secondary combustion.
So it's a very,
very efficient way
of using the fuel in the stove.
And I've got, as I said,
a very short video to show
you that process.
So let's get this fired
up and see it working.
I'll load it up with some simple
kindle, kindling and tinder
here with just some
newspaper and some
dried twigs, which
we push down in here.
If I light the
underneath with a lighter
I've been able to scavenge--
And if you think
that's a massive cheat,
the previous video
to this is how
you can use things
other than lighters
and matches to start a fire
if you can't scavenge those.
And you can use something
like a fire alarm
to start the fire with
or a bottle of water
to start a fire with.
And when it smokes
at the start--
That's why the
epidemic [INAUDIBLE]
for real in the room.
--we'll put a slightly
higher flue on it.
And already, that's
roaring away,
with the air and the
oxygen being drawn up.
So we'll get that going
nice and intensely,
burning down that fuel.
And before I take off
this flue now-- it's
also called a rocket stove,
perhaps for obvious reasons.
If I take off that flue--
So this is just from a
small handful of twigs.
There's very, very
little fuel in there.
If you come in
here and look, you
can see that upper
ring of air holes,
there are jets of
flame coming out there
where the oxygen's
being drawn in
and igniting all those producer
gases coming off from the wood
as it undergoes
pyrolysis and gives off
the vapor and the gas.
And the smoke itself
is combustible.
So burning all of that.
It's a very, very efficient
way of using the fuel.
So I reckon that's
about ready for cooking.
And then I cook
some custard, which
I'd opened in one of
the previous videos.
And the reason this
is important is
it allows you to build
a gasified stove,
but that was more for the
process of demonstration,
but you can also do
amazing stuff like this.
This is a gasifier-powered car.
This is a wood-powered car.
And you basically have
the stove strapped
in a big dust bin on the back.
This is where you drive
that process of pyrolysis.
You use the heat of
combustion to break down
the complex molecules
of the wood,
release those producer
gases and the vapors,
which you then
simply just pipe down
at the cylinders of your
engine, mix with oxygen,
as would happen with
your carborator anyway,
and then drive your
car based on wood
rather than liquid fuels,
rather than fossil fuels.
So this is the
kind of technology,
and again this was done
very, very commonly
in the Second World War.
There were over a
million gasified vehicles
in the Second World War.
And the German army even had
a division of Panzer tanks
that were
wood-powered, that were
driven by these things
strapped to the back of them,
because they were
facing such acute fuel
shortages towards
the end of the war.
So it's this kind of
technology or resurrection
of historical
techniques that you
can use to keep yourself
going in the grace
period of the apocalypse.
But more interestingly,
to myself as a scientist,
was this thought
experiment, this process
of thinking how you could reboot
a civilization from scratch,
how you would actually
go through the process
of rebuilding everything
from the agriculture
and the transport technologies
and the communication
technologies and the
materials and the substances
that all of our lives rely upon.
And, as I said, we
don't really have
any direct sense
of how that works.
And so clearly agriculture and
being able to feed yourself
is one of the key fundamentals.
These are the cereal crops.
All humanity eats grass.
The cereal crops are
all species of grass.
And if you don't
eat wheat directly,
you're eating something
fed the grain,
and they're giving you a steak.
So we all eat grass.
These three crops here,
the wheat, rice, and maze,
have supported civilizations
throughout human history.
The European, Asian, and
North American civilizations
have all been founded on
those three staple crops.
And in the book,
there's a map of how
to find the Millennium Seed
Bank, where you can rescue
heirloom grains, seed
corn, to reboot agriculture
if you can't find
anything in the fields
because it's been too long,
given with the latitude
and longitude coordinates.
And it explains
later in the book
how you can reinvent
those, how you can find out
exactly where this
place is in the world.
You need technology mechanisms
to harvest that grain for you.
And one of the major features
of the history of civilization
has been the application
of power and mechanisms
and harnessing natural
power sources like water,
or wind in this example,
to relieve civilization
from having to use
your own muscles,
from having to go out
into the field yourself
or grind grain into flour
with just a pestle and mortar.
And so the key components
of this windmill
here are these millstones
at the bottom, which
grind the grain into flour,
which you then make bread out
of and then can consume that
nutrition from the grass
that you've harvested.
So in a sense then,
these millstones
are a technological extension
of your molar teeth.
They're a way we've
invented to push
beyond the limitations of our
human body and use technology
to enhance it with
those millstones there.
Pottery and being able to
cook food and ferment food
is an extension of our stomachs.
We've basically invented
external digestive systems.
And there's a whole load
of similar examples.
And it's not just
mechanisms you need
to be able to
reinvent and reboot.
The poster boy of the
Industrial Revolution
was the steam engine and
these big bits of machinery
and the fire and the
power behind it all.
But just as importantly,
there's been the application
of chemistry, of creating
the substances needed
to support civilization,
things like soda
or nitrates for your fields.
And this example
here, again, goes back
to the gasified stove
and the uses of wood,
where if you warm the wood,
it starts breaking down
and gives off all these
very, very useful compounds.
And before the 1900s, and the
application of coal, and then
crude oil is the feed stop for
petrochemicals and everything
that feeds into the
chemical industry today,
it was all timber-based.
This is the more
rudimentary basis
you need to drop back down
to, to leapfrog to, and then
start recovering
your capabilities.
I wanted to show just two
other pictures, slightly more
egotistical.
Because a lot of with research
for this book in writing it,
clearly wasn't
just at the library
or at home reading text
and digesting information.
It was doing things for real
and getting hands-on expertise.
And this is a day spent
in a 1700s blacksmith,
working by a coke-fired hearth
with bellows pumping away,
getting bits of
metal to be red hot,
and then hammering
the life out of them
on an anvil with a big
blacksmith's hammer.
And I created a steel knife
for myself from scratch.
I transformed a blank
of steel into a knife,
which I then, very
smugly, very gleefully,
took home and cut some bread,
and some cheddar and made
myself a post-apocalyptic
cheese toastie from scratch,
and then discovered, immediately
afterwards, a ruinous crack
in the handle of my knife
that I made from scratch.
I'd done a pretty awful job.
But the point behind
this though is
that I now know how to go back
and try again and do better.
And it's that process
of reiteration,
on a microcosm with
me making a knife
for myself, a tool from scratch.
It's exactly the same
process that civilization's
gone through over
thousands of years,
and you want to have some
kind of effort at least
accelerating that process
to perhaps just a couple
of generations or a
couple of centuries.
And if you look on
the inside cover
of the books in your
laps, I was really keen
for the author photo to
not just be a digital photo
that we snapped and chopped
into Photoshop and printed.
This is a photo we
made from scratch.
I went to the Fox Talbot Museum,
where photography was invented
back in the 1830s, 1840s, and
we mixed up the silver chemistry
ourselves.
We made these compounds
from scratch, dumped them
onto a plate of glass, exposed
in a very rudimentary camera
with just a single lens up
front for a 16-second exposure.
It is ludicrously
hard to hold something
that doesn't look like a
death grimace for 16 seconds
without blurring.
And what you can't
see is behind my back,
there is an
honest-to-God metal brace
that clamps at the
base of your skull
to hold your head as still as
possible so it doesn't blur
in this very, very
long exposure.
And that's the reason why most
photos of Edwardian gentlemen
and Victorian
gentleman may look so
funless and joyless because
they're standing still,
sitting still for 15 seconds
with a metal clamp behind them.
The other interesting
thing to point out,
the very simple
chemistry we've used here
is much more sensitive
to ultraviolet radiation,
UV rays from sun, from
the visible light.
So this isn't actually
what your eyes would see.
It's slightly distorted.
And your lips come out as
being very white, very pale,
because they
reflect a lot of UV.
And you're actually seeing into
a deeper layer of your skin,
kind of into the
dermis, which is
why it's a bit more
blotchy and dark.
But I was quite chuffed
to be able to create
a photo for myself and of myself
for the back page of the book.
There's a website linked
into "The Knowledge"
as well with a whole load
of content and the videos
that we created I've
mentioned already.
This is a video about
how to start fire
using only things
from an IKEA shop.
And they're creating
fire blown out
of one of their coat
hangers that I've
found from someone
else and uploaded.
So it's been a lot of fun.
I've enjoyed these
last two years.
And the conceit, at
least, is that this
is the one tome,
the one book you
would need to reboot
civilization from scratch
with all these different
functions of the modern world
you would need to recreate.
I said, there's the website you
can explore for a little bit
more information and detail
and a Twitter stream as well.
But I don't want to
drone on too long.
I thought I'd just say some
things for 15, 20 minutes,
and introduce a bit about
what the book goes on about.
But for me, the most
interesting thing
is talking to you about
it and hearing your ideas.
What would be the most
crucial information
you would want to
preserve if there were
to be some kind of
apocalyptic scenario,
and you'd have to right
back from scratch?
What would be the
crucial information
that you'd want to
have handed to you?
So thank you, guys,
for listening.
I'd say we do have some time
for questions or discussion
or chat.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank
you very much!
LEWIS DARTNELL: Cheers.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: OK, I
have a microphone.
Does anyone have any questions?
Right in the back.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
That was very, very interesting.
So one of the questions was--
so all that knowledge and how
to do all those things
right now is preserved
on things like YouTube and
digital books and things that.
How can we make sure that we
don't lose that knowledge so
that we can actually do those
things when we get to that day?
LEWIS DARTNELL: Well,
a very similar problem
was encountered in the
latter half of the 1700s
when the very first
encyclopedias were being
compiled about people
like Dennis Diderot.
And they came across a
very similar problem.
How can you explain
practical skills
like weaving, or making
nets, or harvesting,
bringing in a harvest
in the fields?
How can you explain these
very practical skills
that you learn over the
course of many years,
working with someone who
already knows how to do it
and showing you and correcting
you if you're doing it wrong?
How can you communicate
and condense that
into just words in an
encyclopedia or perhaps just
some diagrams?
And the only
encyclopedia compilers,
and there's a blog post on
exactly this on the website,
they were acutely aware, perhaps
even more so than we are today,
of just how fragile and
vulnerable civilizations are.
The Roman Empire collapsed, the
Greek civilization collapsed,
the Mayans and Incans, which
we've discovered subsequently,
have all collapsed.
So what could you do
to preserve the sum
total of human knowledge?
And they made genuine attempts
to record everything back then.
We know a bit more
nowadays, so that
would be perhaps impossible, and
even something like Wikipedia
doesn't even come close.
So the conceit, the kind of
cheeky answer, if you like,
up the website is you would
get an iPad or another kind
of tablet, you would
jerry-rig with a solar panel
or an alternator from a car to
regenerate power for yourself
and recharge your
batteries, and you
would download some of
the apps I recommend.
We can rip off, scoop
off videos from YouTube,
and save them on this
hard disk of your tablet.
So when the internet goes
down, which will happen very,
very quickly after the
apocalypse, you've still got,
not just the words of
"The Knowledge" book,
but also these
kind of demo videos
stored for prosperity
as it were.
AUDIENCE: Well, I was
just going to ask,
do you think we might
have been in a better
position to reinvent [INAUDIBLE]
maybe a hundred years ago
before the internet?
Because the internet
makes people's minds lazy,
and you don't have
to know stuff,
because you can look
it up on the internet.
And so, therefore, that's how
civilization spread early,
orally being passed down from
generation-to-generation,
skills, stories,
mythologies, et cetera.
LEWIS DARTNELL: Yeah,
my gut reaction,
my impression is that we'd
probably be worse off today
than a century ago if this
hypothetical scenario were
to happen, if you do have
to go back to scratch.
Because even during
the Second World War,
there was an enormous amount
of ingenuity and problem
solving during the scarcity
of the Second World War,
and most people had an
allotment in the back garden,
and they grew stuff themselves.
They grew vegetables and
food to feed themselves.
How many of us do that today?
No.
There's perhaps not
that many hipsters
in London that have even
got access to an allotment
to be able to grow.
And I did try when
I was living down
in Angel to get an
allotment for myself,
and there was something like
a nine-year waiting list.
So all of these skills
are just dissolving away.
They're disappearing.
You don't repair things
for yourself anymore.
You can't get your
radio and take out
the valve that isn't working
anymore and replace it.
You can't look and understand
the mechanism of the things
we use, because--
You know, your iPhone,
the mechanism inside that
is literally visibly small.
You'd need a microscope to be
able to see the kind of city
landscape of the
circuitry there.
And it's not something that you
could ever repair for yourself.
And in fact, you're
not even expected
to take the back off
technology nowadays.
You just take it
back to the shop,
and a genius will
repair it for you.
And I think that's sad.
I think it's lamentable we're
losing that connection with how
things are made or done
in a fundamental sense.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Really interesting talk.
LEWIS DARTNELL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Two related questions.
As you went through all
of your research for this,
and you were focusing on
things that we were missing,
were there any kind of objects
or processes that you thought,
you know what?
Actually, we could
just forget that.
And kind of related to that,
are there any social constructs
that you came across that you
thought how would we implement
law or government
or whatever it is?
LEWIS DARTNELL: Yeah, so,
two very good questions.
One of the recurring themes I
tried to keep coming back to
through the book
was this network,
this web of scientific
discoveries,
which enable you to make new
technological innovations,
which then allow
you to investigate
the world in a new way and make
new scientific discoveries.
So that kind of back-and-forth
process between science
and technology and exploring
this vast web of knowledge we
have today.
So for example, mastering
the substance of glass
and grinding it into a
lens to build a microscope,
which allows you to explore
the invisible realm.
But with hindsight, we
now know red herrings
we took in history, science,
and technology, or stuff that
turn out to be not all
that very useful, or things
like electricity that
are so useful in so
many different ways you
want to beeline directly
to that gateway
technology, as I call it,
and it opens up a whole
load of other stuff.
So there's a video about
electrolysis on the website,
about how you can use
electricity not just for power
and moving things
with motors for you,
but generating
crucial substances,
like bleach or
chlorine and things.
So you want to leapfrog
something like electricity
and the printing press
for similar reasons
and also the social
ramifications of that.
But, it being a
popular science book,
and already being
quite difficult to fit
all the scientific knowledge
into just 300 pages,
one of the early decisions,
one of the early editorial
decisions was to leave out
more of the social sciences,
the politics and economics
and a description
of how to build a
democracy from scratch.
Because, while undeniably
important, I think
there's a clear distinction
between art and music
and politics and science, and
that science is universal.
The laws will be true no matter
where you are or when you are.
Humanity will have the same
requirements and demands
that technology
must provide for.
So science and technology,
in a sense, are universal,
but politics isn't really.
And my suspicion was if I wrote
this twee little 10-step guide
to building a parliamentary
democracy, it doesn't matter,
because whoever's
got the biggest
gun gets to be the boss anyway.
And they're not going to
relinquish their power
unless you go
through, perhaps, 100,
200 years of social
revolution and slow change.
So you can provide key kernels
or principles of science,
but you can't really do the same
thing for social constructs.
I think they have to arise
organically or naturally.
And it probably wouldn't
make that much difference
if you described democracy,
because it would-- no one would
pay any attention unless
they're ready for it anyway.
You'd perhaps live
with a feudal system
for 50 years or whatever.
MALE SPEAKER: Time for one more.
AUDIENCE: So, thanks
for presenting,
and thanks for the book.
I've been waiting for
something like this
since I discovered
science fiction, because,
all these post-apocalyptic
scenarios,
it's good to know that now we
know how to fend for ourselves.
Personal question for you.
If the apocalypse in
the way you described
came, and 99.99% of the
population with decimated,
beyond locking yourself up in a
supermarket for food and water
for the next 55
years, what would
be your personal next steps?
Medicine?
Go and find the biggest gun?
Something else?
LEWIS DARTNELL: Yeah, so
there's been a bunch of reviews
on the Amazon US site,
and there's allegedly
been a bunch of preppers
who have reviewed
this book about
rebuilding civilization.
And they just love their guns.
And one of the
major questions is,
you haven't talked about
weaponry in your book.
And, of course, it's true.
But again, the resounding bottom
line is, if you've got a gun,
you're fine.
If you don't have
a gun, find one.
It's not an
interesting discussion.
There's no interesting
answer to be had there.
And the knowledge isn't
going to help you either way.
So I avoided guns right
from the beginning,
for the same reason I avoid
the politics and stuff.
But clearly, for this
book to be relevant,
you have to be in a world
that isn't like "The Road."
You have to be
beyond that stage.
This is what happens next.
And you have got some
semblance of stable society,
where people are now
ready to start progressing
and rebuilding, as
happened in 1340s
after the bubonic plague
and the Black Death.
A lot of people died.
People shrugged their
shoulders, stiff upper lip,
and got on with it.
So the next step, the
one piece of information
that I think would be most
critical out of all knowledge
that you would really want
to preserve and not forget,
I've hinted at
already, is this idea
of germ theory and hygiene.
There is nothing you can do more
for yourself to keep yourself
healthy and alive than
stopping yourself picking up
a transmissible infection
in the first place.
And the basic tenets of
germ theory and hygiene
are what will really
help you out there,
when there aren't
antibiotics anymore.
So, we aren't
being too prurient.
Make sure you're not
drinking your own excrement,
making sure no one else
is putting excrement
into the river where you're
taking your water from.
And you laugh now, and this is
obviously a disgusting thing.
As late as the
1850s, 1860s, that's
what happened in London,
the capital of the most
powerful empire
in the world, they
were pouring their poo
into the River Thames,
and someone else 20 yards
down the road, down the river,
was pulling up a
bucket and drinking it.
And tens of thousands
of people would
be dying in a week with
cholera, but for really easily
preventable ways.
So one of the key
technologies I talk about
is how to make a microscope,
ludicrously simple,
to prove to yourself that
there are these organisms, that
are too small to see
that cause disease,
and you want to break that
cycle with things like hygiene.
It demonstrates
scientifically, with evidence,
why this is important.
[INAUDIBLE] I think Rob is going
to drag me onto the tube to--
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, we're
going to go to [INAUDIBLE].
LEWIS DARTNELL: To
your other main site.
MALE SPEAKER: So, please, join
me in a round of applause.
Thank you, Lewis Dartnell.
LEWIS DARTNELL: Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]